o psol hoje vou ensinar consegui com o
sapo total pronto que como vocês podem
ver temos altas ou com o povo brasileiro
disse eu pula e pronto para fazer estes
apelos da equipe foi de impressora a 4
quando todo o nome delas são brancas mas
eu comprei que foi de emissora a 4 e
coloridas tenham se coisa diferente que
eu vou usar que fazer os meus vídeos de
origem e tanto o máximo que consegui
fazer o meu saltar foi quem me sentindo
pronto mas vocês quiserem fazer gostar
aprontar mais poderão fazê lo com uma
cartolina e comenta significativamente a
distância do salto e pronto é fácil
estudar como fazer o bastonário equipas
imagens termais já está curada
aqui usando a minha nova câmera e com a
ajuda de uma luta quantas traziam que a
qualidade estava lá
enquanto as consiga resolver isso e
muito mais a dizer
deixe aqui como a música eletrônica que
o filho é a primeira e ir para um
pessoal espero que gostem e comentem a
época do vídeo da música pronta a
participar mesmo de links que agradecer
à noite estou aqui no início do canal e
foi um salto espero que tenham gostado e
até o próximo biênio
cará cará a a ufa
além do mais por ele e que se não fosse
um câmbio
eu não pensei nem nasce mais lógico só
eu realmente não sabia não estava em bom
jardim não nem vender e dividir entre o
provedor de só para fazer isso ele não
vai lá mesmo